[musique]
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succin 5 mois successivement
pardon Louis Gallois carrière de
fonctionnaires ensuite une gaz chef
d'entreprise la SNECMA ancêtre de safran
la SNCF Airbus
et j'ai fini avec PSA
petit CV de rien du tout c'est
actuellement
co-président de la fabrique de
l'industrie qui réfléchit aux problèmes
industriels donc c'est pour ça que je
suis là capitaine d'industrie vous êtes
notre Jean-Luc Picard de l'industrie
Olivier lui aussi est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement avec
plaisir moi je commence à dire que je
suis un gamin de sous-préfecture en fait
j'ai grandi dans une sous-préfecture de
France puis j'étais aspiré par le
système de la méritocratie à la
française c'est dur de se présenter
derrière le galop donc il faut prendre
un autre angle un peu plus perso quoi et
en termes de carrière j'ai trois vies
professionnelles j'ai été industrielle
alors pas avec autant de mérites que
Louis mais j'ai [grognement] dirigé des
activités de Saint-Gobain sur l'Europe
centrale et orientale j'ai une carrière
aussi de fonctionnaire à peu près 10 ans
je travaille pour la Commission
européenne l'État central un conseil
régional avec la caractéristique d'avoir
été et fonctionnaire et dans les
cabinets c'est à dire de bosser à côté
des politiques donc j'ai eu la chance de
bosser pour Edith Cresson Michel de et
François Hollande et puis depuis une
chance de bosser pour François Hollande
c'était une chanson
et puis depuis quelques années je fais
du conseil donc là je suis associé chez
PwC et juste parce que il faut le
mentionner les propos que je tiendraient
n'engage que moi et n'engage pas PwC
on a décidé de vous faire venir parce
qu'on est très inquiet pour l'industrie
française on est très inquiet pour le
tissu industriel français et les
percussions en cascade que la crise
énergétique va avoir sur notre pays donc
la première question que je vais poser
c'est Olivier pourquoi et comment on en
est arrivé là avec un tissu industriel
menacé alors certes il y a la guerre
comment on en est arrivé là c'est une
carence en termes d'information c'est
une erreur de prospective c'est un
prisme de lecture qui n'était pas assez
profond pourquoi on en est là
il y a deux temps dans ta question court
terme et puis si on remonte un petit peu
plus dans le passé je vais reprendre le
passé juste pour qu'on traite une fois
parce que je préférerais qu'on parle de
la crise là dans les mois à venir et
puis surtout de ce qui va venir 40 ans
de désindustrialisations 75-2015
la France entière adopte la l'idéologie
la façon de penser post-industrielle
l'industrie le faire le fabriquer ça
peut être mis dans les pays low cost
nous on se réserve la conception et le
marketing et donc pendant 40 ans on a
des industrialisés plus que d'autres
pays et le résultat c'est 10%
d'industrie
dans le PIB c'est à dire l'un des plus
faibles taux en Europe le pays
comparatif c'est la Grèce
derrière nous il y a Malte Chypre et
Luxembourg je fais pas de dessin voilà
[grognement] et juste pour donner
quelques chiffres et moyenne européenne
16% l'Allemagne au Sud va donc on est
vraiment au fond ça c'est l'histoire de
la des industrialisation fait très court
une cicatrice je dirais social aussi
toutes les villes ou des usines ont
fermé un résultat macroéconomique avec
le déficit commercial abyssal etc etc
etc
stabilisation pendant à peu près une
décennie 2010 on va dire autour de 2020
OK et puis là maintenant on rentre dans
une autre crise avec la crainte que le
début de rebond qu'on commençait à
sentir j'étais juste un début faut pas
se leurrer se fasse couper les ailes par
la crise de l'énergie et comment on en
est arrivé là sur la crise de l'énergie
si je continue ta question donc là on a
un marché de l'énergie en Europe qui
fait que le prix de l'électricité est
d'un lycée à 100% sur le prix du casque
ou quasiment
on fait la guerre l'Ukraine fait la
guerre à la à la Russie ou la Russie
fait la guerre à l'Ukraine on
suit derrière et on arrive à ne plus
avoir de gaz le prix du gaz explose le
prix de l'électricité s'envole en même
temps et
nos boîtes pour l'instant de pas tout de
suite parce qu'elles sont protégées par
des contrats
notre énergétique avec des contrats qui
découvre sur l'électricité ou sur le gaz
25% des boîtes ont un contrat qui dure
encore 50% des boîtes industrielles ont
un contrat qui s'est arrêté au 31
décembre et donc elles ont maintenant
l'augmentation des prix elle n'avait pas
avant et puis 25 n'avait pas de contrat
mais sans doute si elle n'avait pas de
contrat à long terme c'est que
l'électricité devait pas représenter
beaucoup beaucoup dans leur structure de
coût
on va revenir sur ce sujet Louis est-ce
que vous souhaitez rebondir sur ce que
je voudrais être peut-être plus
spécifique sur la personne la période
2000 2010 je
pense que il faut remonter à Maastricht
on a fait masse très bien
on
est rentré dans Maastricht avec un franc
surévalué probablement 15% par rapport
au 2e marque
on s'en est pas aperçu au début
et puis on était adopté la beauté la
monnaie commune l'euro les Allemands
faisaient les loires
la
les baisses de salaire ou les vraiment
contenaient salaires nous on faisait les
35 heures l'augmentation des charges
sociales et les entreprises les effilées
le salaire l'écart de compétitivité a
explosé entre 2000 et 2010 et c'est
pendant cette période que le processus
que décrivait Olivier qui est un
processus ancien qui a 40 ans s'est
accéléré de manière absolument
destructrice et nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation où effectivement
décide commerciale va être cette année
supérieure à 150 milliards pour 2022
alors il y a une partie qui est de
l'énergie mais il y en a plus de la
moitié qui est dû au produit manufacturé
on se retrouve avec des
territoires détruits
des villes moyennes qui éprouvent de
très grandes difficultés parce que c'est
elle qui avait qui la base du chien
industrielle et les entreprises de
taille moyenne bref le constat est
extrêmement raide et comme le disait
Olivier on sentait qu'on était peut-être
au fond de la piscine et que quelques
bourgeons apparaissaient il y avait
création d'emplois industriels plus de
sites qui ouvraient que ce qui décide
qui ferme et l'investissement industriel
avait repris donc bon on se disait on
est sur la bonne vente là
ça lui coupe les ailes
Olivier a décrit la situation de court
terme la situation de moyen terme
c'est que par rapport aux États-Unis
l'Europe va se trouver dans une
situation extrêmement
difficile le prix de l'énergie 4 fois
moins cher aux États-Unis qu'en Europe
et Biden qui balance un plan de 360
milliards de dollars pour soutenir
l'industrie dite verte il va arroser
toute l'industrie donc ce sont des
subventions en plus les 360 milliards de
dollars la question est qu'est-ce que va
faire l'Europe
c'est moi qui pose des questions ici
rappelez-vous
[rires]
Olivier que va faire l'Europe est-ce que
l'Europe va laisser les Allemands
diriger l'Europe est-ce que en
fait l'Europe c'était un cheval de Troie
allemand ou du moins les Allemands sont
à cheval de Troie les Allemands ont fait
n'importe quoi avec les Russes avec une
politique du dealer de gaz c'est-à-dire
pendant des années ils ont bénéficié
d'une imprégnation
quand
on s'empoisonne avec un truc après après
il en faut toujours plus toujours plus
ils sont fait avoir la
guerre on Ukraine les
a réveillé sur leurs dépenses
énergétiques ça nous a réveillé un
minimum que va faire l'Europe est-ce
qu'on va se retrouver avec une Europe
qui agitent les bras sculpte de la fumée
brasse
de l'air chaud jusqu'au moment où
l'inflation le chômage le tissu
industriel aura émigré ailleurs et que
nous on va se retrouver le bec dans
l'eau en short ou même excusez-moi
l'expression à poil
qu'est-ce que va faire l'europrier
qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire j'aimerais
bien pouvoir répondre ce qu'on peut
constater sur les sur les six derniers
mois c'est que ça pas été très très
brillant pour se mettre d'accord ça fait
6 mois qu'on est en crise je
dirais que l'une des seules décisions
qui a été prise c'est de dire on
achètera pas du gaz à plus de 180 euros
ce qui veut dire grosso modo on arrête
de se faire la concurrence entre les
Français les Allemands et
[raclement de gorge] les autres
européens pour acheter le gaz qui est
disponible et qu'on peut livrer comme
gaz du café c'est quand même un marché
est actuellement un peu moins de 100
euros donc la marge en plus mais on se
dit grosso modo on n'a pas le droit de
se faire de la concurrence entre nous
entre nous à plus de 180 euros donc
c'est quand même un peu limité comme
type de solidarité européenne jusqu'à
présent et comme type de réponse je te
coupe Louis est-ce que l'Europe a
anticipé la guerre oui non est-ce que
l'Europe anticipé les est-ce que
l'Europe a anticipé sa stratégie en cas
de guerre alors si elle a participé à la
guerre comment elle peut anticiper sa
stratégie c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
non le robe n'a rien d'anticipé
d'ailleurs personne n'avait anticipé
cette guerre faut pas se refaire des
idées peut-être que certains stratèges
particulièrement éclairés avait réussi
mais enfin moi je m'attendais pas à la
guerre je suis au dernier moment j'ai
cru que ça se passerait pas bon ça s'est
passé on n'avait pas vu quand la guerre
se déclarée on n'a pas pensé à l'impact
que ça aurait sur le plan économique et
je lui
mais comment on peut balancer ça on n'a
pas pensé à l'impact mais non on n'a pas
pensé je pense que je [grognement]
rappelle que pendant tous les pendant
les quatre premiers premiers mois nous
donnions 600 millions d'euros par jour
à Monsieur Poutine en lui achetant du
gaz et des matières premières bon très
bien donc on pensait on a pensé que ça
allait durer et puis après on a pris des
sanctions on a réduit les volumes et les
Allemands qui sont extrêmement
dépendants du gaz russe comme dire se
sont trouvés complètement squeezée
étranglé et ils ont acheté à n'importe
quel prix du gaz à n'importe quel prix
ils ont rendu le gaz le gaz est devenu
grâce à eux un produit spéculatif et on
a indexé le coût de l'énergie en Europe
sur sur un produit complètement
spéculatif voilà et ce
marché ne fonctionne pas
en octobre le Conseil européen décide de
demande à la Commission du faire un
projet de réforme du marché rien en
décembre Michel le président du Conseil
européen danse la commission dedans vous
allez il faut que vous sortiez un papier
on nous annonce ce papier pour la fin du
premier trimestre 2023
et je j'entendais ce matin responsable
politique français dit nous espérons que
nous aurons une décision avant six mois
inch'Allah six mois pendant ce temps là
l'industrie est étranglée ravagé Olivier
pour rebondir là-dessus
la résultante en cascade de la crise
énergétique est-ce que c'est vous toi
qui a bossé de les politiques est-ce que
c'est un sujet qui les effleure un petit
peu ou est-ce qu'ils sont juste à
réfléchir à très court terme pour leur
mandat et que les questions
soutenabilité de notre société de notre
session industrielle ça leur passe mais
au-dessus de la tête tous les cas les
réactions qu'on a aujourd'hui elles
prennent pas en compte le long terme ça
c'est une réalité on va passer la crise
ça va durer deux trois ans on en
reparlera très certainement mais à long
terme on aura du gaz qui viendra sous
forme liquéfié on sait que le gaz qui va
arriver en Europe sera deux fois plus
cher qui l'est aujourd'hui c'est à dire
un ratio au minimum trois fois plus cher
qu'aux États-Unis c'est une différence
de compétitivité long terme
si on continue à coupler le gaz et
l'électricité on aura aussi une
électricité qui sera deux fois plus cher
donc le découplage sauf aspirer une
balle dans la jambe et dans la poitrine
le découplage il est indispensable plus
vite il est fait le mieux c'est mais il
faudrait donner quelques signes
politique clair si j'investis
aujourd'hui que mon usine démarre dans
18 mois j'aimerais bien savoir un petit
peu à quelle sauce je vais te manger et
aujourd'hui ce type de réflexion là
alors que la crise était difficile à
passer le prix du gaz fait un yoyo mais
sur le long terme on sait qu'on aura un
gaz deux fois plus cher et que si on
découpe le pas gaz électricité on aura
aussi une électricité deux fois plus
cher donc faut donner quelques signaux
on va découpler on va revenir au prix
moyen avec une marge raisonnable pour
investir ces messages-là long terme
aujourd'hui on les entend pas on les
entend pas du tout Louis un capitaine
industrie a besoin de stabilité ici a
besoin de prisme de lecture perforant
sur le long terme est-ce
que vous trouvez que les cabinets
d'intelligence économique que ce soit
privé ou public font correctement leur
boulot c'est du renseignement de pâte à
sel parce qu'ils sont pas sur le terrain
parce qu'ils sont voilà ce qui nous
conduit à l'heure actuelle à pas de
prisme de lecture à moitié bornes voir
totalement aveugle et sourds est-ce que
le capitaine d'industrie commence à voir
notre incapacité à aller
à l'extérieur chercher de l'information
de bonne qualité et surtout une bonne
une bonne synthèse de ce qui est ramené
en France pour protéger notre tissu
industriel vous avez forcément eu des
contacts avec les services de
renseignement économique durant votre
carrière est-ce que vous avez trouvé
j'étais
dans une entreprise un peu particulière
qui est en bus et s'affront aussi safran
et Airbus mais surtout Airbus Airbus ne
n'a pas vraiment besoin des services
d'intelligence économiques il le fait
lui-même et il est plutôt fournisseur
on est meilleur on est plutôt
fournisseur que que client de
l'intelligence par soi-même c'est ça on
le fait la part de nous-même on est dans
le monde entier herbes qui est dans le
monde entier elle
a ses censeur elle fait sa veille
technologique elle fait sa veille
stratégique et en plus elle a l'avantage
d'avoir essentiellement un concurrent
qui s'appelle Boeing alors à partir du
moment où on a qu'un seul concurrent
c'est plus facile de savoir comment ça
se passe mais donc
moi je ne l'ai pas de je n'ai pas
d'exemple que ça nous a été très
utile je ne discute pas c'est pas moi
qui qui était
en contact avec les services
d'intelligence économique c'était le
directeur des affaires internationales
donc il a il avait certainement quelques
informations mais ce n'est pas essentiel
pour nous est-ce que je peux reformuler
entre les lignes en fait c'était des
avec votre service est aimé bien
meilleur que non mais parce que nous
sommes on était spécialisés on savait ce
qu'on voulait connaître l'essentiel pour
une boîte comme Airbus en termes
d'intelligence économique c'est la
technologie c'est de pas se faire
surprendre par quelqu'un qui inventerait
quelque chose que nous n'aurions pas vu
venir c'est la phrase
vous êtes fait surprendre parce que vous
n'avez pas anticipé donc vous avez donc
perdu oui ça fait mal on a perdu si on
se surprendre c'est sûr Alcatel n'a pas
vu venir le téléphone mobile il est mort
de cela il était le meilleur sur le
téléphone fixe du jour au lendemain on
peut pas du jour au lendemain mais en
quelques en quelques années il est mort
à cause de l'émergence du téléphone
mobile Olivier en termes de prospective
les industriels français est-ce qu'ils
sont bien épaulés est-ce qu'ils sont
bien accompagnés ce qui sont bien
protégés on entendait dans le
renseignement économique de protéger la
boîte quand on voit l'espionnage
économique des Chinois des Israéliens
des Qataris des Américains et voir des
Marocains est-ce
que les boîtes françaises sont protégées
et comment formuler ça est-ce qu'on est
en ordre de bataille pour survivre à la
cascade qu'on est en train de se prendre
là aussi il y a deux questions est-ce
qu'elles sont bien protégées certaines
le son parce que Louis vient se protège
parce qu'elle se protège elle-même enfin
j'imagine qu'un groupe comme Total
présent aussi dans le monde entier doit
avoir à peu près les mêmes outils après
on n'a pas de culture d'intelligence
économique alors
globalement collectivement
ok mais quand on va à Bercy quand on
bosse à Bercy comme moi j'ai eu
l'occasion et la chance de le faire je
n'ai pas trouvé ça ma première
expérience d'intelligence économique
elle est pas des grands services j'avais
une usine de Saint-Gobain en Roumanie
j'avais un concurrent turc qui était en
Bulgarie le concurrent il y a
prescription maintenant ça fait plus de
10 ans le concurrent turc payer 50 euros
par mois mon comptable pour avoir la
totalité de ma comptabilité c'est c'est
des voilà voilà ma découverte de
l'intelligence économique à 50 euros par
mois alors quand le salaire est à 300
400 euros ça représente une petite somme
pour la personne en question mais voilà
et ça je l'ai récupéré dans une de mes
premières expériences professionnelles
mais ça a été ma première exposition à
aucun moment donné dans l'univers je
dirais publique que j'ai pu traverser ce
type de réflexion là est vraiment arrivé
encore une fois et quand on a essayé de
faire quelques initiatives sur le sujet
plutôt musclé quand
j'ai eu la chance d'être à l'Élysée nos
diplomates sont effrayés par
d'initiative et donc les arêtes de temps
en temps parce
qu'ils ont peur de la du retour de bâton
de la part notamment des États-Unis qui
sont certains grands partenaires mais
qui aussi ont des intérêts économiques
clairs et qu'ils défendent de multiples
façons dont à peu près tous les secteurs
qu'on peut connaître
oui sous
cet aspect j'aurais dû le dire on a été
quand même aidé c'est-à-dire que les
menaces sur nous
de d'espionnage
pour parler clair les menaces sur nous
d'intelligence économique là les
services nous ont aidés en
nous avertissant et en nous disant
qu'ils avaient des signaux qui leur
indiquaient que il fallait faire
attention sur le téléphone portable
quand il fallait regarder nos
ordinateurs etc donc là
au moins en défensive ils nous ont aidés
un peu des gens que vous engagiez ou pas
du tout il faisait le pedigre et des
gens que vous engagiez ou moi je n'en
fais rien d'accord j'avais dit peut-être
qu'ils ont fait le mien des je
sais que vous travaillez pour les
services ils [rires]
avaient certainement dans l'entreprise
des contacts les
antennes les Allemands aussi puisque
c'est une loi de franco-allemande ce qui
aurait été plus ennuyeux c'est qu'ils
aient que des contacts américains ou
autre parce que nous c'était
essentiellement
les conséquences sur les TPE PME de la
crise énergétique c'est quoi là on
entend les bouchers les charcutiers les
boulangers les petites boîtes faire du
compliquer on va mettre la clé sous la
porte on voit sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs une communication pour aider
les boulangeries aller dans votre
boulangerie locale soutenez vos
boulangers c'est quand même notre
patrimoine
notre art et le meilleur point il est en
France et peut-être en Algérie au Maroc
mais on leur passe le bonjour
comment ça va ça va se passer pour les
petites boîtes à ce que les petites
bosses que là on parle au capitaine de
l'industrie
les petites boîtes qui c'est qui les
protègent qui c'est qui va leur dire
outre que allez quémander un pseudo
bouclier fiscal on vous prend 20% quand
ça augmente de 100 voire 2000%, comment
ça va résister ça déjà faut juste qu'on
mette les chiffres alors on les a c'est
super avec les boulangers on est passé
de 70 à 260 de 70 à 20080 c'est minimum
x 4 en fait 70 c'est un peu élevé
c'était peut-être un petit peu en
dessous donc on est sur un x 4 x 6 quand
on est une boulangerie industrielle on a
la même équation qu'un boulanger fois
d'accord il y a une boulangerie
industrielle il y a plein de boîtes qui
consomment autant d'énergie qu'une
boulangerie industrielle donc la facture
des PMI c'est x 4 x 6 même s'il y a 20%
d'aide on se rend bien compte que c'est
une explosion du prix comme je pense
qu'on en a jamais vu en tous les cas moi
j'en ai jamais vu de ce niveau là et
même quand j'étais en Europe de l'Est
qui était des pays où les prix
l'inflation pouvait évoluer beaucoup
plus vite que ce qui en Europe de
l'Ouest j'ai jamais vu des explosions
comme celle-là qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que en moyenne au
minimum il y a 10% de coûts
supplémentaires directement avec la
facture de l'énergie au minimum et si on
prend l'énergie qui est inclue dans ce
qu'on achète quand on est industriel on
achète des pièces on achète etc c'est au
minimum 20%
donc aujourd'hui les industriels qui
vont fabriquer à partir du 1er janvier
qui avait un contrat jusqu'au 31
décembre ils vont se prendre à peu près
20% de structure de coûts
supplémentaires au minimum donc soit ils
avaient augmenté leur prix avant par
anticipation et c'est vrai que les prix
avaient été augmentés pas mal en 2022
plus que les coûts ce qui fait que les
résultats à la fin 22 sont plutôt bons
d'ailleurs
des résultats sont plutôt bons après la
location des résultats est encore un
autre sujet et donc ils vont pouvoir
absorber une partie mais difficile
d'imaginer qu'il puisse absorber une
telle augmentation de leur structure de
coût donc à un moment donné il va y
avoir des conséquences sur je dirais
l'économie réelle surtout encore une
fois que aux États-Unis il n'y a pas
d'augmentation similaire pas du tout du
même ordre ni en Asie même si la Chine
est pas dans un très bon état
aujourd'hui pour compenser donc voilà
donc on va au devant de choses avec un
effet retard par rapport au
déclenchement de la crise on va dire ou
on commence à en prendre conscience avec
un effet retard qui va quand même puis
qui va être progressif mais en tous les
cas qui est là dans l'économie réelle il
est là cet effet oui vous souhaitez
rebondir ou pas du tout j'abandonne
totalement pour ce concert de les TPE
c'est les toutes petites entreprises
le gouvernement va faire des choses
parce que c'est quand même une sur le
plan électoral s'appelle très lourd donc
le gouvernement va faire des choses et
puis ils ont une capacité à se remuer on
l'a vu avec les boulangers
moi je suis inquiet également pour les
entreprises de taille plus grande je
parle pas des grands groupes je parle
des ce qu'on appelle les entreprises
intermédiaires les ETI les grosses PME
etc ces entreprises elles sont très peu
protégées à la différence de ce qui se
passe en Allemagne en où elles sont où
elles sont elles vont être très bien
protégées ou bien en tout cas
rappelez-nous ce que l'Allemagne est en
train de sortir de cet objet
je ne sais pas si Bruxelles la trouvera
un plafond de 160 euros le Megawatt
au-delà duquel 70
euros de 70% de la consommation
supplémentaire de la consommation de
l'année précédente sera couverte à 100%.
c'est très c'est un peu compliqué ça
veut dire qu'en gros 70%
de leur chiffre d'affaires de leur de
leur facture sera couvert au-delà de 160
euros le mégawattheure et nous n'avons
pas l'équivalent nous n'avons pas
l'équivalent en France nous avons des
protections elles sont beaucoup plus
limitées et le couvriront jamais que 15
20% de la facture donc je pense que nous
allons avoir une difficulté pour ces
entreprises trois solutions soit elles
augmentent leur prix
soit elle baisse leur résultat et
s'endette soit elle s'en vont et moi je
crains je crains la délocalisation
certaines feront failli ils peuvent
faire faillite et moi je crains la
délocalisation aux États-Unis
probablement
dans des zones où l'énergie est bon
marché et les États-Unis ajoutent cerise
sur le gâteau à une
énergie pas chère les 360 milliards de
baiden donc il y a un pouvoir
d'attraction extrêmement fort sur une
partie de l'industrie européenne ça ne
concerne pas que la France l'Allemagne
est extrêmement inquiète de ce qui est
en train de se passer mais pourtant
Macron s'est déplacé voir Jojo il
lui a dit ce que qu'il souhaitait que ça
ne que que les entreprises qui exportent
vers les États-Unis puisse en bénéficier
bon c'est bien si c'est possible il y
aura une discussion je pense que les
Américains vont lâcher un peu de l'Est
mais ça comprends pas très loin le
geste de ils vont lâcher un peu de l'Est
j'avais l'impression que vous l'ancien
votre clébard oui mais je pense je pense
que ça va être ça ça va être quelque
chose de relativement symbolique je
j'espère que ce sera mieux heureusement
symbolique parce que les Américains ont
besoin de ce plan parce qu'ils ont en
face de la Chine et le vrai combat il
était avec la Chine pour eux l'Europe
est fait collatéral
les subventions allemandes les aides
européennes on en est où là qui prend
quoi qui est quoi sur le volume total
des aides européennes la France ça
représente combien de pour cent
l'Espagne combien de pour cent les
Allemands combien de pour cent vous avez
une idée ou c'est trop compliqué une
table ronde hier et la Commission
européenne a révélé quelques chiffres
dans les aides qui ont été donnés c'est
plus de 50% en Europe c'est plus de 50%
de l'Allemagne pour les entreprises
allemandes un petit van 25% pour la
France 25% et puis 7% pour l'Italie des
autres pays étant derrière donc
l'Allemagne ce taille de la part du lion
assez clairement dans cette répartition
est-ce que l'Europe est en train de
juste un mot l'Allemagne a
compris que ça serait pas européen ne
souhaite pas que ce soit européen il est
en train de faire soigner une fashion
réduction acte
en Allemagne avec l'argent allemand
parce qu'ils ont la capacité de
financement et le reste de l'Europe il
s'en foutent ce
petit accent qui va bien le comment vous
dites le
programme de vider des 360 milliards
s'appelle comme ça on
voit pas très bien que le lien avec
l'inflation mais enfin bon très bien
c'est
comme ça je pense moi que les Allemands
sont en train de faire leur inflation
de réduction actes et alors que je pense
que la France devrait demander qui est
un inflation de réduction acte au niveau
européen financé par l'endettement
européen évidemment c'est chiffon rouge
pour les Allemands
il
y a un rôle de l'Allemagne mais il faut
pas non plus qu'on néglige trop nos
propres nos propres faiblesses et nos
propres faillites si on en est là
aujourd'hui avec nos 10% de l'industrie
dans le PIB clairement c'est pas que la
faute des Allemands et par rapport à une
situation et situation où on est décalé
vers le bas quoi qu'il arrive si on veut
réindustrialiser la France il faut pas
attendre je dirais le plan européen qui
va nous sauver il faut qu'on se prenne
par la main nous-mêmes on est tellement
décalés vers le bas qui est ou pas la
crise de l'énergie il aurait fallu qu'on
fasse une politique française pour nous
ramener au niveau moyen européen sans
doute enfin sans ça encore une fois on
irait nulle part donc regardons nous
aussi un petit peu dans ce que on a fait
et ce qu'on peut faire pour nous il y a
évoqué tout à l'heure la question de la
demande un petit peu aller chez le
boulanger pour acheter votre baguette
ben pareil sur beaucoup de choses la
commande publique les achats des grands
groupes dont l'état est au capital
cet aspect là sur la mobilisation de la
demande pour acheter du made in France
afin de sauvegarder notre industrie
pendant cette crise on ne voit pas non
plus je pense que c'est vraiment un
discours facile à tenir tout le monde
sera d'accord pas si difficile à mettre
en œuvre notamment sur la commande
publique avec les textes actuels on peut
acheter du made in France il faut juste
pas le dire et mettre les bons critères
sociaux environnementaux dans les appels
d'offres et on aura une fine du made in
France il faut pas faire un
peut-être [grognement] sortir de
l'Europe la France je me fais l'avocat
du diable non je voudrais quand même
approuver ce que appuyer ce que Olivier
on a la France a fait un plan non
négligeable les 200 milliards allemands
la France c'est 120 milliards donc c'est
quand même pas quoi le problème c'est
qu'en France on a l'essentiel du plan a
été mis pour protéger les ménages
et d'ailleurs ça fait que le taux
d'inflation en France est inférieur à
celui de l'Allemagne parce que l'État a
financé une partie donc
il en reste moins pour l'industrie les
Allemands ils font l'inverse ils sont en
train de faire payer leur ménage
et l'argent massivement va l'industrie
et donc ce sont deux choix c'est deux
choix différents qui ont été faits donc
c'est pour pardon quel est le meilleur
ah je pense que du point de vue de
l'industrie c'est le choix allemand il y
a le meilleur mais je reconnais que
politiquement le choix le choix français
a du sens il s'agissait de limiter la
casse en matière de d'inflation et ça a
un effet également bénéfique c'est que
ça limite les hausse de salaire les
Allemands vont être obligés de faire des
hausses de salaires assez forte mais ça
harde loin quand même mais ils partent
ça
a beaucoup beaucoup changé les salaires
en Allemagne ont largement redécolé
la protection sociale aussi avec ou pas
du tout pour d'autres choses sociales
elle est correcte alors elle est
financée très différemment de la France
une grande partie et n'est
pas public et privé mais il y a une
protection sociale qui est quand même de
très grande qualité en Allemagne vous
parlez allemand non Olivier oui juste
pour rebondir sur ce que disait Louis
dans les titres des journaux on a
beaucoup vu les 200 milliards allemands
la somme fantastique en fait quand on la
compare au volume d'aide français les
120 milliards le décalage par rapport à
notre économie notre population 20 à 30
40% de plus le fait que l'Allemagne a
trois fois plus d'industries que la
France qui est très consommatrice
d'énergie globalement c'est pas là qui
la véritable question la véritable
question il n'est pas sur l'enveloppe
c'est la manière dont elle est répartie
avec un choix très clair qui a explicité
Louis sur pour en Allemagne en défendant
un tissu industriel et un choix en
France qui qui interroge parce que la
précédente crise le covid on a eu France
relance
on se relance c'est 100 milliards
d'euros là on est à 120 milliards c'est
comparable François Hollande c'était 30%
pour l'industrie là c'est 10% pour
l'industrie et donc la question c'est on
fait des choix politiques ok très bien
mais il faut un peu de continuité où est
la continuité d'un côté en soutien
industrie on a plein d'usines là qui
vont sortir de terre parce qu'elles ont
eu des subventions France relance deux
ans après les projets sont faits ont
commencé à les monter donc on soutenait
notre industrie la crise de l'énergie
arrive 10%,
on la met devant des factures d'énergie
x 4 x 6 Olivier d'un peu sévère parce
qu'il compte pas France 2030 il y a 54
milliards quand même qu'il a sont très
fléchés sur des innovations de rupture
qui concernent l'industrie qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par innovation de rupture
c'est quoi c'est les bras des batteries
au graphène d'hydrogène c'est le compte
le quantique c'est l'intelligence
artificielle c'est l'exploration des
fonds marins etc des choses qui sont il
y a 14 programmes de ce type là c'est
beaucoup plus crédible que le haras de
licorne c'est
quand même non je pense que c'est assez
bien foutu honnêtement je pense que
c'était assez bien foutu il y a 14
thèmes je trouve il y a peut-être 3 ou 4
de trop mais c'est pas mal foutu
alors oui alors ça sachant que ça c'est
plutôt long terme oui c'est très long
alors que on parlait de plan d'aide
premier point et puis deuxième point les
54 il faut un peu les décortiquer il y
en a 10 qui sont déjà passés dans France
relance il y en a la moitié qui
réservait à l'innovation et la recherche
globalement l'investissement productif
dedans et TD c'est la hauteur de 17
milliards dans France relance pour
l'avoir bien décoré une différence là
avec Olivier je pense que tout ce qu'on
met dans la recherche en France c'est
bon pour l'industrie
et
moi d'ailleurs de mes questions c'est
l'effort de recherche en France qui est
insuffisant alors je vais vous poser une
question comment on fait pour
réindustrialiser quand on a pas
d'énergie il est la deuxième question
parce que vous me l'avez on a de
l'énergie le nucléaire et
[grognement]
je pense que c'est
clair que la croissance économique
génère des besoins d'énergie
et les normes
erreurs que l'on a fait sur les 20
dernières années
c'est de croire qu'on allait avoir
besoin de moins d'énergie alors que si
on a de la croissance la croissance
génère de besoin d'énergie alors on
s'aperçoit maintenant qu'il faut de
l'énergie et de l'électricité et donc je
pense qu'il faut lancer très rapidement
le programme nucléaire ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas faire de
renouvelables mais renouvelables c'est
c'est de résoudrons pas l'équation ne
serait-ce que parce que le renouvelables
et intermittent et que il n'est pas
assuré tant qu'on sait pas stocker cette
énergie renouvelable le renouvelable
sera accessoire par rapport à des
énergies pilotables des carbonées comme
le nucléaire donc il faut mettre
l'accent sur le nucléaire il faut se
dépêcher parce que c'est très long
d'investir dans le nucléaire les faits
est un disque 15 ans et je crois qu'il
faut s'y mettre maintenant très
sérieusement avant de redonner la parole
à Olivier il y a un truc qui me choque
c'est on n'a pas compris que si on
voulait de la croissance fallait de
l'énergie
mais n'importe quel gamin de 14 ans qui
joue sur un jeu de stratégie basé sur
les ressources je vais vous donner un
exemple il y a des jeux qui ont des jeux
de stratégie de basé sur ça depuis
d'aller comment ça se fait qu'on a des
politiques je pense que ça se fait qu'on
a pas des industries qui sont avec des
battes de baseball en disant écoutez les
gars vous êtes bien gentil à brasser de
l'air chaud à faire de la subordination
de vote à acheter la paix sociale avec
le compte de la France avec public
maintenant ça suffit non on gère nos
boîtes comme des bons paires de famille
on paye des impôts maintenant vous
arrêtez vos conneries pourquoi on ne
voit pas un groupement de par le MEDEF
ok pourquoi on voit pas un groupement de
de mec balaise dans l'industrie dire
maintenant ça suffit vos conneries on a
bien compris que vous étiez des
incompétents finis
maintenant il y en a pas un de vous qui
a bossé dans une boîte je dirais pas ça
alors dites-le comment non je pense
qu'on a confié l'énergie au ministère de
l'Environnement c'est-à-dire à
l'écologie et que l'énergie a été eu
sous le prisme de l'écologie et qu'on a
absolument pas regardé quel serait les
besoins internes je me souviens du
responsable de fermeture de Fessenheim
auquel je disais mais enfin on ferme une
centrale nucléaire qui vient d'être
remise à niveau qui pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a fait un manie mais parce que
nous n'aurons nous aurons besoin c'est
en 2016 pas si vieux que ça en 2016 nous
aurons besoin de beaucoup moins
d'électricité dans l'avenir or nous
aurons besoin probablement de deux fois
plus d'électricité sur que ce que nous
avons un
détail
il y a eu une intoxication collective
non il y a eu une intoxication allemande
avec un lobby les
Français ont accepté l'intoxication je
suis désolé il y a eu tout en courant
qui
considérait que la sobriété énergétique
était était atteignable et que donc il
fallait pas investir dans ce type
d'énergie je rappelle qu'on a fermé 13
gigawatts de capacité de production
d'électricité sur les 10 dernières
années à
la fois du fossile et Fessenheim
il
[rires]
y a des solutions en plus la conviction
profonde les industriels qui se
mentalisaient en disant maintenant vous
arrêtez vos conneries puis
après pourquoi est-ce que les
industriels ne protestent pas plus fort
alors comment industrialiser un One
électrifie parce que demain encore une
fois je reviens le gaz sera plus cher si
on arrive à changer ce marché européen
on peut encore espérer avoir de
l'électricité compétitive pardon
quel cuivre le
cuivre il y en a il y en a non non
comment
ça il y en a du cuivre dans
les nodules polymétiques sur la surface
de l'Inde au
Chili il y en a dans sa zone de pays je
pense qu'il y a d'autres métaux qui sont
un peu plus critiques que ceux que le
cuivre et sur lesquels je
m'interrogerais un peu plus que que le
cuivre mais bon deuxième point Louis la
mentionné il faut on est dans un monde
d'évolution technologique d'innovation
fondamentale final on a France 2030 il y
a de l'argent toujours discuter sur
quelle est la bonne sous enveloppe qui
va bien écouter magique ou pas voilà
mais ça ça va dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'on sait que il y a un
syndrome de technologie sur lequel il
faudra être on pourra pas être surtout
ça c'est certain mais par contre il y en
a quelques-unes sur lesquelles on peut
espérer avoir un rôle de leadership
comme on a eu le leadership sur le
nucléaire pendant beaucoup de décennies
pour
passer et puis
c'est pas intoxication allemand les
Allemands ont eu un débat ils sont
anti-nucléaires pour des raisons qui
sont probablement liées à leur passé
alors
passé et aux guerres qu'ils ont susgés
donc
et
ils sont en dénucléaires et je pense
qu'on ne les fera pas facilement revenir
là-dessus même il préfère nettement
utiliser de la limite du Charbon Pour
faire de l'électricité avec du nucléaire
bon le problème c'est que nous avons
accepté nous de nous engager sur une
voie comme celle-là parce qu'on s'est
dit si les Allemands font c'est que ça
très bien et je pense qu'on a pas
personne moi je suis comme vous
abasourdi de voir à quel point pendant
20 ans on a laissé
tomber toute prospective électrique les
programmation
plus réelle de l'électricité la PPE de
l'énergie pardon
actuellement on rigole quand on la relie
on rigole quand on rigole quand on la
relie je rappelle que c'est pas vieux
c'est 2020
la dernière bouture vous rigoler parce
que c'est sous dimension parce que c'est
complètement décalé par rapport à la
réalité on est sur des prévisions de
consommation extrêmement qui sont
absolument pas celles que l'on va
constater si on arrive à
l'industrialiser bien évidemment si on
bazar de l'industrie là le problème est
réglé on a pu on a besoin de beaucoup
moins d'électricité en plus on apprendra
à fermer le éteindre la lumière en
quittant la pièce on
[rires]
a dit l'innovation OK et puis il y a
tout un sujet qu'on a complètement
oublié c'est les PMI et les ETI dans les
territoires qui ont des projets qui ne
sont pas de l'innovation fondamentale
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont pas derrière le
laboratoire de recherche public ou
privée qui utilisent la dernière thèse
le dernier brevet mais qui font de la
tech quand même ce qu'on appelle de la
lothèque ou de la Mitek et là il y a des
dizaines et des milliers de projets qui
existent le potentiel on va pas le
chercher on le développe là et ça me
permet de faire le lien avec ton autre
question qui est pourquoi est-ce que les
industriels finalement ne protestent pas
plus moi j'ai le sentiment que
l'industrie en France c'est encore la
fille sage de l'état du 19e c'est-à-dire
on attendait toutes les l'état on sait
pas si sache que ça à l'époque on va on
va négocier dans les alcôves des
ministères on va [rires] négocier dans
les alcôves des ministères on va pas
faire le rapport de force sur la place
publique comme l'on fait les
agriculteurs ou bien les artisans et on
voit les boulangers mais la société
autour de nous elle a changé un rapport
de force maintenant politique n'existe
plus il est pas sur la place publique
donc il y a toute une culture de
communication qu'il faut ré-acquérir et
que aujourd'hui l'industrie n'a pas tant
que ça et moi je pense que il faut que
les chefs d'entreprise s'exprime mais il
faut surtout que leur salarié s'exprime
leurs ingénieurs leur techniciens leurs
ouvriers il faut qu'ils s'expriment et
il faut de leur donner la possibilité de
s'exprimer pourquoi il faut les laisser
s'exprimer pourquoi
il faut il faut qu'il développe et
qu'ils disent pourquoi il faut de
l'industrie dans ce pays et également
pour dire que l'industrie c'est c'est un
métier d'une très grande noblesse on
prend de la matière on la transforme on
fait des choses on fabrique ça se voit
en ce mental on fait des choses
concrètes donc je pense que ce sont de
très très beaux métiers et en plus on a
besoin d'industrie on a besoin
d'industrie pour nos villes moyennes on
a besoin d'industrie pour équilibre nos
comptes on a besoin d'industrie pour
acquérir minimum de souveraineté on a
besoin d'industrie parce que c'est elle
qui porte la recherche dans les sciences
dures et donc la solution pour
l'environnement et donc et on a besoin
d'industrie on a besoin d'industrie pour
l'environnement il n'y a pas de public
qui porte les sciences dure pas le privé
ça devrait être le public l'État qui qui
met la qui qui est la capacité de
financer la science la recherche non il
y a les entreprises aussi financent mais
70%
ça vient de l'industrie Olivier
on a les problèmes environnement la
transition énergétique et écologique
chaque fois qu'on aborde un problème il
y a un produit industriel derrière on
parle du solaire faut des panneaux la
voiture électrique c'est un produit
manufacturier la voiture électrique il
faut il faut des batteries les matériaux
la viande végétale il faut il faut la
fabriquer le recyclage le recyclage des
produits c'est de l'industrie le
recyclage du produit c'est de
l'industrie etc l'industrie elle est
partout c'est 20% de la consommation
d'énergie et c'est 100% des problèmes
des solutions des solutions des
solutions je suis désolé je reprends la
parole Olivier ça me permet ce petit
lapsus me permet de repérer sur un autre
truc j'espère qu'il est pas significatif
là
on se retrouve avec des industries qui
ont menti
je prends l'industrie du pétrole qui
depuis environ 1970 c'était au courant
que leur activité
fournissait un réchauffement climatique
on a vu exon les derniers papiers d'exon
sortir
est-ce que l'industrie se remet en
question par rapport au dommage
qu'elle a créé qu'elle peut créer ou
l'industriel fait ce qu'on lui demande
parce que il est bête et discipliné il a
été un exemple qui n'est pas celui de
l'énergie c'est Volkswagen la fraude la
fraude sur le diesel
Volkswagen en a tiré ils ont viré le
patron ils ont complètement transformé
leur politique
parce que ils se sont aperçus que
c'était irrité la vie de l'entreprise un
problème de réputation qui pouvait les
tuer ils se sont vraiment collé
au problème et ils ont obligé toute
l'industrie automobile à regarder ça de
très près et je pense que moi j'ai été
j'étais chez PSA à ce moment-là le
diesel le Volkswagen gate on l'a pris
dans la face parce que on est venu
investiguer chez nous on a trouvé
évidemment les trois mails qui peuvent
créer problème enfin ça n'a pas eu de
suite et donc ça
a créé un véritable ébranlement dans
l'industrie ça a fait d'ailleurs que ça
tue le diesel ce qui ce qui a été un peu
rapide un peu rapide un peu rapidement
Fabien c'est un tuile diesel mais ça a
failli tuer Volkswagen donc les ça
a créé un traumatisme qui a fait que
l'industrie automobile a beaucoup changé
après ça et puis après aussi
tu présentes l'industrie qui doit faire
si on met à culpa ou qui doit
reconnaître qu'il y a eu d'après
variation sur l'environnement de manière
énorme faut pas oublier que l'industrie
ça sert un projet de société l'industrie
de production enfin d'un production de
masse ça répond à la consommation de
masse on est en train de changer de
projet de société c'est assez clair je
sais pas bien dire les termes qui vont
définir c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas
encore les trois termes sociétés de
consommation de consommation de masse on
les a pas pour le futur sobriété
circularité ça va tourner autour de ça
l'industrie elle est en train de se
mettre au service de ce projet donc
demain ce type de sujet là et ben
l'industrie apportera des solutions
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec lui l'industrie c'est 20% des des
émissions et c'est peut-être un peu
moins que 100% des solutions parce que
je pense qu'on a changé nos
comportements aussi mais il y a
clairement une grande partie de la
solution qui sera des nouveaux produits
qui seront circulaires démontables
réparables et que la société va demander
encore une fois l'industrie ça n'existe
pas pour soi ça existe pas en soi ça
aide ça c'est au service d'un projet de
société on est en train de changer quand
on dit l'industrie verte par exemple ça
donne un petit peu envie de sourire
parce que il n'y aura pas d'industrie
qui ne sera pas verte demain sinon
elle aura des problèmes de réputation
elle se fera surtaxée elle passera pas
dans les marchés elle se fera laminer
par les règlements donc toute
l'industrie est en train d'évoluer à fur
et à mesure que notre société est en
train d'évoluer alors le problème c'est
que dans le monde entier l'industrie
prend pas ce virage au même prix il y a
des endroits où nous prenons le virage
assez rapidement l'Europe est quand même
un des endroits où le virage se prend le
plus vite il faudrait pas qu'on prononce
virage nous soyons complètement démenté
c'est à dire que les autres industriels
continuent à produire du carboné des des
de l'acier carbonique que nous on se met
à l'acier des carbonée qui va coûter 20
30% plus cher donc on
va
retrouver le point d'équilibre entre les
deux entre le virage à prendre c'est
c'est clair je crois que les industriels
maintenant sont tous conscients et en
même temps le fait qu'il faut quand même
garder une certaine compétitivité sinon
on va avoir afflué en Europe des
produits fabriqués ailleurs qui auront
des caractéristiques environnementales
beaucoup moins bonnes que les produits
européens et puis avec des politiques
qui ont un peu une vision globale de ce
qui se passe par exemple le principe de
la taxe carbone aux frontières pour nous
protéger par rapport à des lieux de
production qui ont pas les quotas
carbone etc sur le principe c'est super
bien mais tel qu'elle est faite
aujourd'hui elle protège que les
industries de base et donc ce qu'on
appelle les filières alval c'est à dire
les produits transformés eux vont être
face à une concurrence déloyale donc
on prend une direction
on doit assumer qu'on est les pilotes
sur le sujet qu'on voit les plus vite
mais après faut une certaine cohérence
dans les politiques qu'on met en oeuvre
certaines compréhension de ce que c'est
qu'une chaîne d'approvisionnement et ça
de temps en temps on trouve pas et taxe
au carbone aujourd'hui si le principe
est excellent est superbe l'application
d'une complexité extrême parce que
effectivement une voiture fabriquée en
Turquie et qui n'applique pas avec de
l'acier qui
a été fabriqué avec du coq et dans des
conditions d'émissions de CO2
en
Europe sans
difficulté l'acier lui-même ne pourrait
pas y rentrer mais à travers la voiture
il va y rentrer et ça c'est un véritable
sujet c'est d'une complexité extrême et
un manque de vision à la base je pense
c'est à dire qu'une vision globale
quelle industrie on veut comment je suis
pas sûr que que je crois que le problème
a été vu mais on ne sait pas de résoudre
et comme on a voulu faire un geste
politique on a annoncé cet ajustement
aux frontières que qui était de bon sens
on a voulu faire un geste politique mais
je pense que on n'a pas la solution
lorsqu'on regarde la chaîne de
production la chaîne de valeur des de
cette acier de ce ciment qui va être
dans des sous dans des produits qui eux
ne seront pas protégés alors une
question un peu plus complexe
l'intrication des actions des boîtes
industrielles réparties sur certains
fonds de pension portefeuille de fond de
pension
et dont
le paiement des retraites de certains
fonctionnaires américains français ou
autre si c'est américain parce qu'il
faut que je sois français oui je suis
d'accord avec vous
[rires]
si les industries baissent si leur
cotation baisse leur action baisse le
rendement baisse induit
[raclement de gorge] au changement
climatique à la transition énergétique
ou parce que l'industrie se vautre parce
qu'il y a plus d'énergie bon marché les
répercussions que ça va avoir sur ces
marchés financiers est-ce que c'est
anticipé pas anticiper ce que ce virage
est compris pas compris est-ce que ma
question était trop nébuleuse pour me
faire comprendre non mais les premières
conséquences que telles que je les
comprends enfin l'industrie c'est 10% de
du Pipe français donc même si ça réduit
allez on va dire ça réduit de 20%
scénario catastrophe ça fait 2% de
baisse par rapport à la totalité du PIB
par rapport à une croissance normale je
dis pas que c'est pas l'épaisseur du
trait mais globalement pour la
macroéconomie bon ok par contre si on
voit les conséquences sociales Louis a
parlé des villes moyennes qui ont été
désindustrialisés et qui est certaine je
veux dire une faillite d'une entreprise
industrielle qui est le plus gros
employeur dans une ville moyenne il y a
pas que l'entreprise qui fait fight il y
a le territoire qui part derrière il y a
ça il y a des questions de souveraineté
comment
est-ce qu'on veut être maître de notre
destin collectif quand on n'a pas une
industrie de pointe qui permet de
résoudre un certain nombre de questions
on est le pays de pasteur sur le covid
on a quand même pas brillé voilà donc
[grognement] question on a brillé on a
mis des affichettes Charles de Gaulle on
a brillé par notre incompétence n'a
briller par notre nonchalance le pays de
pasteur chez nous il y a un peu des
toubibs et on a bien rigolé de voir la
panique de gens qui n'ont pas anticipé
qui n'ont rien ils ont pas vu une
rupture une rupture technologique qui
est la RN
je
suis dans une assemblée générale de
pasteurs mais pour pasteur ça a été une
claque absolument terrible ce qui
travaillait sur un autre vaccin sur un
vaccin classique
et ils se sont aperçus que c'était l'ARN
messager qui va être travaillé sur la RN
messager comme les et ils s'en sont
aperçus trop tard c'est un peu comme
Alcatel qui travaille qui devient le
meilleur sur le téléphone Unifix et je
pense que ça nous fit a été un peu dans
la même situation et donc ils ont été à
côté de la plaque ça prouve d'ailleurs
que la veille technologique avait pas
été bonne là la veille technologique a
pas été bonne alors ça c'est sur
l'innovation tous
les produits de tous les jours
aujourd'hui vous allez dans une
pharmacie doliprane antibiotique de base
pas dispo pour les gamins on va pas
mettre la France à genoux pour ça mais
c'est un style un espèce de doute quand
même sur la capacité de notre pays de
notre tissu industriel ça c'est de
l'industrie de base c'est pas
l'industrie la plus high tech et la plus
diptec pour reprendre cette ces
anglicismes donc ça aussi c'est
l'industrie les quelques points
d'industrie qui nous manquent ils
permettent aussi de se rassurer par
rapport à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement sur les choses de
base encore une fois des produits qui
peuvent exister depuis 5 ans ou 100 ans
et puis le dernier point qu'on a évoqué
si on veut vraiment si l'Europe veut
être leader sur la transition écologique
il va falloir réinventer toute une série
de produits manufacturés la voiture
c'est le premier exemple mais n'importe
quel produit qu'on a autour de nous va
devoir demain être démontable réparable
recyclables en dernier ressources en
dernier recours tout ça il faudra bien
que c'est des produits industriels si
notre industrie se met pas là-dessus on
sera la remasse en Europe si l'Europe
devient leader voilà tout ça c'est les
enjeux qui sont derrière la même chose à
mon avis plus que le paiement de la
retraite dans les fonds américains c'est
un peu notre dada ici j'ai l'impression
ici on veut pas se faire surprendre il
faut essayer
de pas se faire surprendre en
France encore sur la veille
technologique
je pense qu'il y a des bois de
françaises c'est
un effort collectif les chercheurs
c'est le chercheur qui vole qui voit les
choses arriver du plus loin il y a les
chercheurs il faut les écouter il faut
les écouter parce que c'est ils
savent beaucoup de choses parce que eux
ils sont en contact avec la communauté
mondiale il faut qu'il faut
il faut les écouter il y a les
entreprises qui ont leur propre réseau
j'évoquais Airbus
mais les autres aussi et
puis les
services hépatiques ont le rôle Olivier
évoquait tout à l'heure les ambassades
il
va falloir savoir ce qui se passe en
Corée par
exemple la Corée qui est un pays que je
connais un peu et est un pays qui me
paraît formidablement intéressant
regardez parce que le sud Corée du Sud
plutôt Corée [rires]
du Nord j'ai beaucoup d'affection mais
enfin c'est pas pareil la Corée du Sud
ça paye 50 millions d'habitants qui n'a
aucune matière première qui fasse à des
colosses comme la Chine le Japon et la
Russie ses frontières qui est en guerre
avec le nord et ce pays de 50 millions
d'habitants c'est le plus connecté de du
monde c'est un pays qui a été capable de
générer Samsung et LG c'est un pays qui
est qui qui a montré parce qu'il s'est
pris en main qu'on était capable de de à
partir d'une base très faible je
rappelle que c'est un pays extrêmement
pauvre en 1950 c'est des pays les plus
pauvres du monde actuellement c'est un
PIM par habitant qui est supérieur dans
une Espagne donc c'est un pays qui a
fait qui a explosé et je pense qui nous
donne des indications sur le type de
politique industrielle qu'on peut mener
parce que ils sont en économie ouverte
ceci c'est pas pour dictionnistes il
faut quelquefois des petites misères
mais ils sont pas globalement
protectionnistes une remontre il nous
montre qu'on peut faire de la très belle
industrie dans un pays qui n'a pas les
ressources minières
ou autres que qui avantage par exemple
les États-Unis et je pense que ça c'est
c'est très important pour nous qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe dans ces pays là
est-ce qu'il fait est-ce qu'il faudrait
qu'on revive
ce petit moment historique difficile
pour faire émerger des leaders dignes de
ce nom c'est-à-dire les Coréens du Sud
je
ne souhaite pas que nous traversions les
mêmes difficultés
les
périodes d'abondance génèrent des
leaders aussi pertinents qu'un filet
d'eau tiède et les périodes dures font
émerger des gens des leaders des des
points de vue long terme des des
stratégies long terme et des choses
comme ça en sortant de la guerre Conseil
National de la Résistance toute une
évolution Bernard et zambert avec
Pompidou qui nous fait le programme
thermonucléaire sur le compte d'une
table je
vais vous dire quelque chose de
qui a pas presque scandaleux
c'est un patriote
c'est quelqu'un qui aime son pays et qui
a décidé qu'il y avait décidé parce que
maintenant il est quand même comme moi
retiré des voitures mais il avait décidé
de se
mettre au service de son pays et je
pense que ça c'est très important le
patriotisme c'est une valeur qui n'est
pas enseigné
qui n'est pas enseigné moi je voudrais
que le corps enseignant en soit pétri
pour le passé aux
jeunes et la Corée je reviens en Corée
le patriotisme et il est spontané parce
qu'il y a la guerre avec la Corée du
Nord il est spontané mais je vois la
force que ça représente regardez le
patriotisme chinois la force que ça
pardon
c'est aussi un danger mais
il faut trop de patriotisme il faut pas
de nationalisme il faut le patriotisme
c'est j'aime mon pays
mais je suis ouvert aux autres cultures
je suis ouvert au reste du monde c'est
ça le bateau dit moi je suis je suis je
me considère comme patriote bienvenue au
club je j'aime ma langue le français
parce que j'ai été éduqué là-dedans mais
j'adore l'italien j'adore l'espagnol
j'avais un peu moins l'anglais mais
enfin bon chacun à sa langue j'aime
l'allemand c'est une très belle langue
il
faut boire je
suis je suis convaincu que au-delà des
mesures techniques il faut inventer un
récit pour l'industrie et il faut le
porter par du patriotisme et de
l'Industrie et de la française de la
tripe de la tripe mais des émotions des
émotions des émotions des gens qui
travaillent dans l'industrie qui portent
leur j'ai l'impression d'écouter
François Ruffin
c'est un homme qui a fait un film
formidable qui s'appelle merci patron
genre eu encore
[rires]
[grognement] Olivier pardon il fait des
blagues et nous voilà
on [rires]
en est où parce que quand on dit
patriote maintenant c'est ça a
été ça a été volé ou ça a été
instrumentalisé par les adversaires de
l'extrême droite on
a plus le droit de se réapproprier notre
drapeau parce que vous comprenez avec
les mecs de l'extrême droite qui se
balade avec des drapeaux français on a
pas le droit d'être fier de des couleurs
de notre pays on n'a pas le droit d'être
patriotes on n'a pas le droit de faire
de protectionnisme économique et puis
surtout on n'a pas le droit de critiquer
le protectionnisme économique des autres
c'est quand même une drogue gravissime
non est-ce qu'il faut pas que les
Français se réveillent et réveillent
leur vieux démons moi je n'enploie pas
le terme protectionnisme j'emploie le
terme réciprocité les autres nous
laissent pas accéder leur marché public
inaccepte pas aux autres
les autres mettent du taxe sur les
bagnoles nous mettons des taxes sur les
voitures je pense que il faut sortir de
de cette idée de
cette idéologie européenneiste
qui fait que on est ouvert et que
l'Europe est ouverte je suis pas pour le
protectionnisme parce que nous sommes en
économie ouverte on a besoin d'échanger
mais je crois qu'il est absolument
essentiel que on applique le principe de
réciprocité et on va s'en apercevoir
avec la Chine on a accepté la Chine au
sein de l'OMC alors qu'il ne respecte
pas les règles il subventions de
l'industrie dans des conditions qui sont
totalement destructrices pour la nôtre
pour le solaire on l'a vu ils ont balayé
le solaire européen en 4 ans
et sur la réciprocité juste pour qu'on
donne un élément 80 à 85 % des marchés
publics européens sont ouverts à la
concurrence étrangère dont américaine
les États-Unis c'est moins de 30% qui
est ouvert donc on voit les quarts
monstrueux c'est pratiquement
de réciprocité c'est pas simplement des
petits ajustements c'est des gros
ajustements qu'il faut refaire un
questionnement sur la façon dont on a
fonctionné pendant des années donc c'est
économie ouverte n'est pas avoir le
caleçon sur les chevilles c'est ça
absolument et quand un pays aide son
industrie dans des proportions qui sont
excessives
il paye des taxes pour vendre ses
produits chez nous
et par exemple sur une fashion réduction
actes il y aura pas d'autres solutions
que de faire à peu près la même chose en
Europe sauf à se planter et
faut-il
dépasser le patriotisme pour résoudre
les l'interdépendance des énergies et
des économies je répète la question
faut-il dépasser le patriotisme
pour aller au niveau européen je vous
résoudre l'interdépendance des énergies
et des économies
le patriotisme n'empêche pas de
l'échange je rappelle qu'on échange de
l'électricité en Europe depuis 50 ans on
n'a pas attendu le marché unique
créé par la Commission et
c'est tout à fait normal on échange on
va pas ça arrêter de faire du commerce
entre les différents pays mais il s'agit
de savoir
quels intérêts défend et puis les
échanges économiques ou même la
juridiction qu'on choisit elle peut être
dissociée de l'identité patriotique
qu'on défend je vais prendre un exemple
en Roumanie vous êtes un citoyen roumain
c'est à dire que vous appliquez le droit
roumain mais vous dites que vous êtes
votre culture votre nationalité elle
peut être allemande Rome ou bien
roumaine donc on peut vivre au sein de
l'Union européenne avec ses échanges en
ayant des identités des nationalités
différentes et on les affirme
question Internet
que pensez-vous des différentes
interventions de BPI France banque
publique d'investissement dans la
réindustrialisation ainsi que le soutien
des entreprises françaises je
trouve que BPI a été un succès c'est un
succès quand
on dit banque publique d'investissement
tout le monde a dit ça y est le Gosplan
qui revient et je trouve que BPI a été
atteint
succès d'une part parce que avec l'aide
du programme d'investissement d'avenir
il a été capable de créer un marché des
startups et du financement des startups
je pense qu'il n'y aurait pas le
financement des start-up que nous
connaissons actuellement en Europe qui
commencent émerger à devenir en volume
intéressant c'est-à-dire qu'on est
capable de trouver maintenant sans 200
millions pour une entreprise alors que
avant on trouvait 20 millions bon on ne
trouve pas encore un milliard comme aux
États-Unis on trouve 100 200 millions
donc on est il y a un progrès je fois
qu'on le doit BPI et je crois aussi que
l'abpi a été capable de mobiliser une
partie du tissu économique par la
totalité mais avec une politique de
communication de grande qualité ils ont
été capables de mobiliser une partie de
l'appareil économique et avec leurs
accélérateurs etc ils sont un support de
ce qu'on appelle la french femme French
oui c'est French Fab French tech je
rentre très
bien qui sont qui ont été créés par
l'État et que BPI soutient et je pense
que s'il le fait plutôt bien il peut pas
tout faire papa tout faire et il reste
quand même en bout de chemin à faire
parce qu'encore une fois le financement
des entreprises et notamment
industrielles en France elle est
notamment en fond propre reste plus
faible que nos partenaires économiques
européens même il y a à peu près 10
points de différence en France la PMI se
défend ce finance plus par la dette que
par du fonds propres donc la BP déjà
fait un superbe parcours il nous en
reste encore un sacré bout de chemin à
faire là dessus c'est vrai qu'il a la
BPI à moins d'instruments pour faire des
fonds propres que pour faire du de la
dette enfin des leviers ils ont quoi
j'ai pas compris ils ont moins ils ont
moins de capacité à faire du fonds
propres il le font en intervenant dans
des fonds qui des fonds d'investissement
ou de ils prennent un ticket dans un
fond d'investissement pour le stimuler
et c'est ce fond d'investissement qui
apporte des fonds propres donc il serait
peut-être souhaitable que l'avait payé
un peu plus de moyens pour faire du
front propre et là-dessus il faudra il
faudra mobiliser l'épargne des Français
Encore une fois là-dessus on peut
revenir dessus en fait on n'a pas de
problème d'argent en France pour
financer une réindustrialisation par
exemple il fallait pas une des Français
c'est 5500 milliards juste en produits
financiers on
peut estimer qu'il faut être 300
milliards pour remonter notre niveau
industriel au niveau moyen européen en
plus des investissements classiques
c'est juste une question de tuyaux c'est
juste une question de tuyau de tuyau
de priorité l'assurance
vie c'est 1800 milliards d'euros il y en
a moins 10% qui va vers l'industrie donc
il y a une marge de formidable seulement
ça sert à financer la dette de l'État
ça c'est quand même pas absolument
négligeable et en plus ça ne veut on ne
prend pas de risque parce que les gens
ils mettent de l'argent en assurance vie
justement parce qu'il y a c'est pas
risqué l'État
qui tient l'assurance vie bon c'est pas
risqué pour la France la signature de la
France est encore respectée c'est ça
c'est pas risqué c'est-à-dire que quand
vous prenez un quand vous faites un
placement de votre épargne en assurance
vie vous avez à peu près vous allez
retrouver votre mise vous prenez pas de
grand risque ne donne pas de conseils
financier vous
ne prenez pas de grand risque mais ça
veut dire que les gestionnaires
d'assurance vie qui sont les compagnies
d'assurance elle
ne prennent pas de risque non plus donc
elles investissent dans les bons du
Trésor allemand dans la dette française
qui est une dette de bonne qualité etc
et donc aimer
investir dans les entreprises c'est
prendre des risques
alors il y a une petite partie de
l'assurance vie qu'on appelle
l'assurance vie en nuisette compte
excusez moi du langage qui va vers les
actions et donc vers une certaine prise
de risque mais cette prise de risque
elle est extrêmement limitée puis c'est
c'est investi dans les valeurs les plus
traditionnelles les plus stables etc
c'est pas du tout investir les startups
alors il faudrait que ça aille vers les
startups le message vraiment c'est que
nous n'avons pas de problème de moyens
de ressources notamment
on a un problème de priorité et de
volonté de ce qu'on veut faire de cette
fantastique ressource qu'elle épargne
des Français qui orienté comme l'a dit
Louis aujourd'hui et pas vers des objets
productifs qui nous permettraient
d'avoir la souveraineté la sécurité
d'approvisionnement la cohésion des
territoires parce que c'est du boulot
dans près des villes moyennes et dans
les territoires et puis une capacité à
répondre aux enjeux environnementaux
encore une fois il y aura une partie de
nos comportements qui vont changer mais
la voiture électrique c'est un objet
magnifiqueucturé il faudra bien le
réinventer partout vous y croyez la
électrique
un énorme bullshit ça est-ce que c'est
il faut moi je crois la voiture
électrique mais je pense qu'il faut dire
aux gens ce que c'est il faut pas leur
dire que c'est la panne assez
universelle il faut pas leur dire que
c'est clean dans bout à l'autre parce
que on utilise des matériaux
qui ont des impacts écologiques non
négligeables lithium par exemple les
mines de lithium c'est pas très propre
et il faut beaucoup de lithium dans les
automobiles on utilise du cobalt qui est
extrait par des enfants au Congo et
traité ensuite en Chine qui nous revient
cette manière là on va peut-être faire
des batteries sont cobalt mais pour le
moment il faut du cobalt donc on sait
pas très bien quoi faire des batteries
une fois qu'elles seront en fin de vie
il
y a bon il faut expliquer tout ça si on
veut véritablement avoir le bilan de la
voiture électrique et si en plus on les
recharge avec de l'électricité allemande
qui est au charbon au charbon ou aux
limites là on est on produit plus de CO2
qu'avec une automobile en
Allemagne il faut 150 000 km pour qu'une
voiture électrique produise moins de CO2
que le voiture à essence en France c'est
100000 km
donc il faut expliquer ça aussi mais je
pense qu'on va vers la voiture
électrique d'ailleurs on va vers les
usages électriques c'est pour ça qu'on
va avoir besoin d'électricité parce
qu'on va faire on va on va développer la
fabrication d'hydrogène d'hydrogène
de voiture vous pardon vous avez quoi
comme voiture 208 essence excusez-moi
électrique
[rires]
j'ai 208 essence mais donc
mais je crois que les usages de dire
électrique il va nous falloir beaucoup
d'électricité la voiture sera électrique
elle sera peut-être hydrogène dans un
avenir un peu plus lointain mais si elle
est hydrogène sera électrique parce que
pour fabriquer l'hydrogène il va faire
beaucoup d'électricité la décision sur
la voiture électrique je pense qu'elle
est symptomatique de ce qui nous arrive
on est dans un monde politique avec une
décision qui a été prise sur un symbole
c'est magnifique c'est formulé j'adore
et le symbole c'est je veux plus du
diesel et je veux la bagnole électrique
ce qui est en train de vous arrivez avec
la transition écologique etc c'est que
plein de sujets n'ont pas une réponse
simple et on va réintroduire il faut
réintroduire dans le débat public tout
ce savoir des industriels des ingénieurs
pour répondre à la question la voiture
électrique c'est bien dans un certain
nombre d'usage mais peut-être que la
voiture thermique ça va être mieux pour
l'environnement dans d'autres il va
falloir un peu avoir ce discernement
qu'on a qu'on a oublié il faut vraiment
réintroduire ce savoir-faire dans le
débat public
alors il n'y a pas si longtemps la
France l'Europe devait être le leader
sur le photovoltaïque aujourd'hui la
Chine à la main mise sur la fabrication
ne pensez-vous pas que la Chine attend
que l'Europe l'âge de l'argent est sans
dette pour du développement et après il
rafle la mise sur la production par du
dumping pour le drake la messe a été
extrêmement facile à dire c'est une
industrie qui a été archi subventionnée
en Chine archi subventionnée pour tuer
l'industrie européenne ils ont réussi
sur les 10 premières boîtes qui
fabriquent des panneaux photoïques
neuves sont chinoises mais nous nous
sommes laissés faire parce que lorsqu'on
nous aurions pu mettre des barrières
antidumping j'ai
un souvenir terrible d'un déplacement de
la chancelière allemande en Chine qui
est revenu de ce déplacement en disant
non il y a pas de dumping la première
réunion technique au niveau européen
avait lieu 15 jours après
parce que le commerce allemand avait
compté et là on a sacrifié on a sacrifié
notre industrie photovoltaïque est-ce
que aujourd'hui on pourrait récupérer et
remonter
c'est pas évident il y a une avance
technologique qui est prise il y a des
outils productifs même s'il y a une
rupture technologique est-ce qu'on
serait capable de refaire une industrie
du photovoltaïque il y a des il y a des
avis assez divergents
non je partage totalement cet avis
d'ailleurs je constate que dans les
énergies renouvelables les panneaux
photovoltaïques sont tous chinois ou
presque nous ne fabriquons en France pas
les éléments des pales pour les les
éoliennes donc nous sommes très
dépendants de l'importation nous n'avons
pas développé en France et en Europe
pour le photovoltaïque les bases même
des énergies renouvelables et nous
allons le payer parce que nous allons
beaucoup apporter et ce sont des
énergies qui sont subventionnées donc
faire un levier de la subvention
publique qui est le tarif de rachat
j'achète des énergies renouvelables il y
a une partie de subventions faire un
levier sur une capacité de production
européenne ou française c'était
imaginable on l'a pas fait on n'a pas eu
le réflexe d'adosser une politique
environnementale de NR à un outil
productif on n'a pas eu le réflexe
d'adosser une politique de santé à un
outil de productif de santé on est passé
de la première à la quatrième place donc
il y a ces corrélations aussi à faire
une politique publique a besoin de son
outil productif derrière pour lui
assurer de la stabilité de l'innovation
de choses
on a dépensé 120 milliards d'euros sur
les énergies renouvelables en France
c'est la Cour des comptes qui a fait qui
a mesuré 120 milliards d'euros
avec 120 milliards d'euros on n'a pas
été foutu de bâtir une industrie des
énergies renouvelables les hôpitaux
achètent 20 milliards d'euros par an
on n'a pas été foutu avec ces 20
millions d'euros par an de faire une
industrie de la santé en
France on importe quand on voit dans un
hôpital on apporte jusqu'au lit de
d'hôpitaux de foutu
c'est un peu résumé pour
réfléchir c'est très simple parce qu'on
a voulu limiter la dépense son assurance
maladie donc on a systématiquement
choisi
le moins cher et le moins cher c'est
celui qui est fabriqué en Inde pour le
principe actif il est fabriqué en Inde
on nous pousse à utiliser produits
génériques j'utilise moi-même les
produits génériques parce que je suis un
ajout en consomme donc 78
ans bientôt 79 c'est
le vélo c'est le vélo donc
je
crois que on n'a pas utilisé les outils
qu'on aurait pu utiliser
je suis entièrement d'accord avec
Olivier on avait des outils formida on
nous a pas utilisé au dépens 120
milliards sur les énergies renouvelables
on n'est pas foutu de faire une éolienne
sans importer on n'est pas foutu de
faire un panneau photovoltaïque je pense
après avec des dépendances qui sont là
le nombre de produits où on est
dépendant à 80 % les antibiotiques les
principes actifs de nos médicaments il
faut bien réaliser derrière ce chiffre
un peu théorique de dire ah on a
beaucoup des industrialisés on est
arrivé à 10% la moyenne européenne est à
16 l'Allemagne est à 20 ok ça c'est des
chiffres macro mais ça se sent dans
notre vie au quotidien Aujourd'hui c'est
pas que les emplois c'est aussi encore
une fois l'histoire de la pharmacie où
on trouve pas les produits quand on en a
besoin les industries de guerre là les
industriels sont prêts à se mettre en
ordre de marche du moins faire un effort
de guerre si on se castagne ouvertement
avec les Russes juste une question quand
on voit sur des secteurs clés de notre
industrie être projeté en Chine et on a
pu de contrôle dessus l'armée
elle va pas voir le politique en coucou
on a fait une étude sur les risques
bactériologiques et chimiques on sait
jamais bon c'est peut-être un état
renégat qui va financer un mouvement
pseudo terroriste si nous font une
attaque bactériologique et chimique ah
[raclement de gorge] vous savez pas quoi
bah on a vu d'antibiotiques on a vu de
paracétamol on est en short les gars ils
vont pas voir les politiques
heureusement
ces produits sont fabriqués dans
beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde
paracétamol bah c'est drôle bientôt sera
pas avec en France d'ailleurs merci de
me rassurer lui c'est très sympa que
j'ai pas mal fréquenté dans ma carrière
l'industrie
d'armement c'est quand même une de celle
où il y a eu une politique industrielle
on
a eu la continuité avec avec la
désorganes publics Délégation Générale
alors maintenant et des industriels des
industriels qui s'organisent le
groupement industrie aéronautique
et spatial le GIFAS c'est vraiment une
organisation qui fonctionne bien et ça
c'est ça crée ça une
industrie ça fait c'est pour ça qu'on
atteint les ce qu'on a d'assaut qu'on a
airbuste
une question c'est mon côté un peu
hippie l'industrie de l'armement
l'industrie de guerre c'est pas un peu
boomer il faudrait peut-être qu'on fasse
autre chose non moi je pense que
Monsieur
Poutine vient de nous donner la réponse
à la question que vous posez oui alors
ça c'est facile quand même oui mais
c'est facile il y a des tensions
géopolitique comme il y en a pas eu
auparavant si vous avez des diplomates
aussi branquignole pas capable de sentir
la température montée pas capable
d'anticiper la guerre avec des services
j'ai pas terminé pas capable d'anticiper
la guerre pas capable de voir nos
vulnérabilités et laisser les politiques
partir en short à la plage avec 50
degrés au soleil il
faut remettre les choses à leur place
quand même parce que l'industrie de
l'armement c'est bien ils font leur chou
gras avec des problèmes diplomatiques on
n'est pas capable de régler un sourire
coûte toujours moins cher qu'une balle
[grognement] certes
il faut avoir la capacité de répondre à
ce qui nous sourit pas mais il va
falloir peut-être un jour se poser la
question est-ce que le véritable ennemi
c'est la guerre elle-même peut-être non
et que avoir des lobbies de l'armement
l'industrie militairement industrielle
ou le lobby militaire industriel ça va
bien 5 minutes
c'était un truc de boomer quoi c'est un
peu comme les vendeurs de club non moi
je suis à peu près en désaccord total
avec ce propos donc c'est à dire que je
pense qu'on a besoin de se défendre
qu'un pays comme la France a pensé
défendre il peut pas se défendre s'il a
pas une industrie d'armement c'est un
cervement il faut qu'elle exporte parce
que sinon elle n'aura pas la base de
production qui permettra de servir et
besoins désormais françaises je pense
qu'on a une grosse capacité
technologique on n'a pas encore la masse
de production industrielle que
nécessiterait une guerre de haute
intensité on est adapté actuellement
notre appareil de production est adapté
à des guerres de basse intensité type
Mali et autres on n'est pas notre base
n'est pas adaptée notre base industriel
n'est pas adapté à
à une guerre de haute intensité on n'a
pas assez de munitions passer de
missiles d'ailleurs j'ai compris que le
gouvernement essayait de pallier cette
cette insuffisance avec il a lancé des
programmes donc moi je pense que on a
dans
le monde dans lequel nous vivons
dépenser 2% du PIB pour se défendre
qui est l'objectif que c'est fixé la
République c'est c'est c'est correct
non
joue les Allemands ils seront on en
parlera les [rires]
Américains sont évidemment à 4% de
hors PIB donc c'est clair nous ne sommes
pas mes 2 % c'est quand même quelques
objectifs si vous voulez que je vous
lâche tout question quel est l'avenir
pour l'industrie minière ah ça c'est un
vrai sujet si
on choisit la souveraineté si on choisit
un axe de souveraineté parce qu'on
considère que le monde devient très
instable et que les routes
d'approvisionnement notamment des métaux
dont on aura besoin pour la transition
écologique peuvent être coupés il va
falloir et ouvrir des mines pourquoi pas
ça se fait si on choisit un angle
purement environnemental où on veut
respecter tous les espaces naturels dans
ces cas on va voir des problèmes le
projet de mine de lithium des ramettes
est à mon avis un super cas d'école on
va voir comment ça va se passer mais
notre société a un choix notre société
col on a un choix à faire quelque part
et c'est pas blanc ou noir ce sera un
équilibre mais entre une certaine
sécurité d'approvisionnement et puis un
respect total où on acceptera quelques
zones ou sur lesquelles on va prendre
sur l'espace naturel c'est un vrai débat
de société mais il est devant nous et à
mon avis on aura besoin mon point de vue
c'est qu'on aura besoin d'un peu de mine
pour assurer un minimum de sécurité
d'approvision tout voilà stratégie des
lieux de Meuse qui a sécurisé son
approvisionnement en métaux
[soupir]
et puis aujourd'hui tous les grands
groupes industriels se posent la
question et ceux qui vont considérer que
les métaux ça s'achetaient à la bourse
du LMA ou bien auprès de trader ils sont
en train de redescendre la chaîne
vérifier la mine qui les fourni ceux qui
les transforment pour savoir s'ils sont
bons ou pas bons et ils se commencent à
sécuriser leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement on le voit partout
qui
est le rapport au Varin qui est
intéressant il faut maintenant que
passer à l'acte
bon question Internet vous comptez
prendre votre retraite à quel âge les
gars là
pour
prendre ma retraite c'est [rires]
comme les chevaux de course quand ils
prennent leur retraite je
suis trop vieux pour demain c'est pas de
moi c'est de banquier français
[grognement] un petit approfondir sa
phrase la dette française est une dette
de bonne qualité la
dette française bonne qualité parce que
la
capacité à rembourser cette dette et
considérée par le marché comme forte
pour ça que nous sommes la dette
française est bien notée elle est moins
bien notée que la dette allemande pour
ça que nous avons une petite différence
de taux d'intérêt entre la France et
l'Allemagne mais la Banque de France
c'est bien ça et et le ministère des
Finances verra c'est bien ça c'est bien
que ce qu'on appelle le spread entre la
France et l'Allemagne c'est à l'écart
entre la France et ça croit pas donc ça
veut dire que nous sommes en Europe une
des dettes de meilleure qualité de la
meilleure qualité
ce qui est d'ailleurs quelque
chose un actif qu'il faut défendre
et un certain nombre de politiques je
pense aux retraites si on peut être
inspirés par la volonté de montrer au
marché que on fait des choses qui
protègent notre
la solvabilité de notre dette
c'est pas une question c'est
pas une question c'est un commentaire
d'abdela monsieur Gallois est un grand
philotrope il donne beaucoup d'argent
aux associations sans trop en parler il
faudra lui rendre hommage de ce côté là
vous en parler c'est
[rires]
très agréable d'entendre ça mais je ne
sais pas de me dire cette information
est
un radin il regarde bah oui je préfère
ça c'est très à la mode les radins
sobriété maintenant on va tous radin ah
non mais sobriété ne veut pas dire radin
ça j'ai l'impression d'entendre ma femme
me parler je
suis très honoré ceux
qui pratiquent la sobriété ne sont pas
radins il [grognement] faut arrêter avec
ça on a mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire
que penses-tu de la nouvelle voiture
limitée à 2 litres au sang
c'est un objectif ambitieux mais pas il
est totalement irréaliste à quel prix et
surtout alors ça c'est une grande
discussion que j'avais quelqu'un qui
travaille dans le spatial et qui disait
c'est très très bien de faire des
petites voitures à pas cher et qui
consomme pas beaucoup le problème c'est
que tout le monde va en acheter et que
le résultat des courses infinés tout le
monde va consommer beaucoup plus ça
veut dire qu'il vaudrait mieux que les
produits qui émettent du CO2 soient
réservés aux riches comme ça il y en
aurait pas trop et ça
me paraît un argument très très fort
auquel je m'associe vous vous êtes de
gauche moi je suis en républicain
[rires]
peut-être pas très connu mais le soleil
va mourir des choses comme ça quand
j'étais ado soleil vert ça vous parle
bien sûr le film moi
je connais le film j'ai
vu le titre du film j'ai pas vu le jour
vous le conseille aussi vous
êtes plutôt soleil vert ou soleil jaune
je
vais vous demander de nous conseiller
trois bouquins
qui ont compté pour vous vous
avez le droit de sortir un de vos
bouquins dans les trois
exceptionnellement mais au moins
donnez-nous trois bouquins qui ont
compté dans votre vie Olivier dans notre
vie la
Belle du Seigneur Cohen superbe histoire
d'amour dans un contexte d'institutions
internationale un peu Kaf Cayenne le
contraste était vraiment qu'est-ce qu'il
y a d'autres sinon après un peu de
poésie
sans doute Rimbaud mais plus enfin
quelques poèmes du style de bateau ivre
que j'ai adoré Apollinaire vous kiffez
un peu ou pas du tout un petit peu mais
pas pas autant et puis quoi d'autre
encore
après si une lecture récente que je peux
recommander aux
gens qui auraient pas découvert ce type
de pensée et de philosophie c'est Bruno
Latour ou atterrir que moi j'ai
découvert alors je m'attendais à ce que
tu utilises le terme de boomer à un
moment donné dans cette interview t'as
pas pu t'empêcher voilà bah moi c'est
quelqu'un un Millénium qui m'a qui m'a
une Millenium qui m'a recommandé ça et
une superbe lecture éclairante alors
c'est encore partielle mais par rapport
au projet de société dans lequel on se
projette c'est une première fenêtre
ouverte écris des bouquins toi moi j'en
ai écrit pas mal ouais le dernier c'est
vers la renaissance industrielle c'est
Marie B avec Anaïs vegillis c'est pas
vrai mais bien sûr l'innocent
[rires]
et puis sinon j'en ai ouais j'en ai
écrit d'autres j'en ai fait à peu près
un à chaque fois que j'ai eu une un
changement professionnel donc ça fait il
y en a certains que j'ai pas publié pas
après après l'Élysée j'ai rien publié
mais j'ai écrit quelque chose c'est un
peu des reflets de chacune de mes
expériences avant avant d'entendre les
trois bouquins de Louis un commentaire
donc pas un commentaire c'est une
question qui dit et on n'est pas foutu
de virer tous ces faiseurs de plomb
pourri
[grognement] hein bon la prochaine fois
que vous venez vous allez répondre à
cette question les trois bouquins alors
le premier qui m'a vraiment
bouleverser ses Vies des stands aussi du
Haussmann
si j'ai un bouquin à recommander pour
apporter sur une
île déserte c'est celui-là
si j'en cherche un autre j'ai 1793
Victor Hugo
c'est un bouquin formidable actualité
les gars pas très long j'ai
besoin de sortir d'actualité pour le
soir 1793
c'est un bouquin formidable et en plus
c'est un bouquin de Victor Hugo qui fait
moins de 2000 pages donc et
parmi les essais je pense que c'est
fourqué qui est qui a fait qui
a vraiment mis
le doigt sur un certain nombre de choses
j'y ajoute Guy Louis
que je trouve excessif parfois mais qui
pointe des choses qui me paraissent
parfaitement aigus
comme la sécession des riches et je
pense que c'est un phénomène massif en
France extrêmement préoccupant c'est que
la société française est en train de se
cloisonner et les riches sont en train
de faire sécession
c'est-à-dire ils
ont leurs écoles ils ont leur lieu de
vacances je j'ai une maison à Belle-Île
alors je sais ce que c'est que la
sécession je
vois bien que nous sommes en train de
tromper son touche combien par an ah
mais j'étais moi j'étais prisonnier ça
a varié parce que comme j'ai eu quelques
difficultés avec mon conseil
d'administration sur ma rémunération
puisque j'en ai refusé une partie à un
certain moment c'était
quand la dernière année c'était 4
millions
vous pratiquez l'évasion fiscale en
grand alors [rires]
avant de vous lâcher à cause de lui
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
Olivier quelque chose d'intéressable une
bouteille à la mer rêver grand pour nous
faire un beau projet et des générations
comme moi on sera derrière vous pour
vous aider à le mettre en œuvre mais
prenez la main laissez-nous pas penser à
votre place parce que un projet de
société c'est pour 10 ans 20 ans à
monter comme un projet comme un outil
productif et donc dites nous ce vers
vous vous avez envie d'aller et vous
pouvez compter sur des gens de notre
génération pour vous aider à le faire
avec toute notre expérience nos réseaux
etc oui pensez par soi-même
pas être le le pion de la pensée des
autres pensez par soi-même ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut connaître la pensée des
autres il faut se cultiver il faut être
curieux il faut regarder le monde autour
de soi mais à la fin il faut penser par
soi-même et je pense que c'est ça qui
donne la capacité à agir
alors avant de vous remercier d'être là
je dis demain interview interview
économie interview en version originale
anglais préparez-vous messieurs je
voulais vous remercier c'était trop
court mais c'était pas mal et c'était
bon il va falloir revenir vous faites
une belle équipe tous les deux merci
merci à vous merci merci de de tenir
compte de mes contraintes
tout [rires]
de suite il faut enlever le micro et on
coupe les missions
[musique]